foreign
[Music]
Fazbear's pizzeria where fantasy and fun
come to life hit it guys
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're watching this video
it means you've been selected as
Freddie's newest security guard
hello
we're going to have so much fun together
[Music]
[Applause]
when there are scary things we don't
understand
our minds try to fill in the blanks
Sometimes the best thing to do is to
face it
so this light is going to be completely
solid like it is right now
and gradually it's going to start
flashing until it's totally dark
so you can see that there's nothing to
be afraid of
okay
see that's not so scary is it
just you your sister and me
you're doing okay
[Music]
stop me okay
in your head
[Music]
Kitty there's something in my room
can you believe me
don't you
there's no such thing as monsters you
need to grow up
I'm serious Sawyer I need to be alone
you're both having these manifestations
what is this what is this supposed to be
not paying attention
[Applause]
dad you have to listen to me okay
I'm listening
sweetheart let me handle
[Music]
are you ready we're ready to forget the
further once and for all
[Music]
my brain just been foggy past few years
all I ever wanted was to be a good dad
adulting
[Music]
foreign
to college you still have a few weeks
before your students show up right just
an idea to reconnect I know it's been
tough with you too
[Music]
the balance of light and dark is what
we're after you're an art school I take
it yeah you go here too yes
draw and experience that defines you
when I was 10.
it was in a coma
but I don't even remember being sick
sink deep into your memory
and let's see what life can find
I'm seeing crazy stuff
I think these drawings could be Clues
from my past there's so much you don't
know and I was too scared to tell you
the truth our family has been keeping
secrets they suppressed our memories but
I can still feel something following us
there's only one way to find out
foreign
I feel like I'm getting closer to
something
if something's getting closer to me
when you awaken the Dead the further you
travel the riskier your journey will
become
the Demeter
on Charter from Romania to London
shipping private crates
content unknown
out at Sea with no land in sight
this year's comments he's a doctor
dress like a learned man University of
Cambridge and on my way around the boat
our Charter has agreed to pay bonus for
timely arrival in London
let me show you the ship this here is
huckleberry
we don't come with like this to give the
use clear
ly
[Applause]
something ripped about the animals
on the livestock this looks like a bite
search the ship everywhere
evil isn't worked
powerful evil
thank you
[Music]
guys
in night it drinks our blood he's just
here
we call him Dracula
[Applause]
he's coming
see the size of that Bloody things
[Music]
he is on this ship which means we will
never leave it the devil is real
may God have mercy on us all
right
have you seen the group chat you're
doing it again tonight
huh
no please what's my mom's Remembrance
Day I just want to forget about it huh
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll do it
cannot go for more than 90 seconds am I
clear what happens after 90 seconds
don't want to stay
like the candle to open the door
blow it out to close it
dude
put your hand on it
now say
talk to me
[Applause]
[Music]
talk to me
what does the hand feel like
so amazing I can't see and feel
everything on the other side
so my mom she was trying to reach out
um
I'm here
still been seeing stuff you've been
saying stuff
what if we open the door but we didn't
shut it
oh my God they followed us
I like it
they're not gonna stop
we're never gonna stop
they like you
[Music]
on June 16th
stop playing wait hold up I know I left
this door see the horror film
preview audiences are calling a killer
experience
probably runs on racism
oh
you've sacrificed the person you deemed
the blackest guys I can prove I'm not
the blackest prove it I thought black
Twitter was a type of seasoning I like
Jimmy Fallon without the roots and wrong
I voted for Trump
what
twice
your time is up it's time to die
car cops
[Music]
[Applause]
we need a plan please get some weapons
wait chili powder girl what I'm gonna do
cook sorry though
everybody everybody
know let's dance
[Music]
can we just go lock the doors get down
I'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]
Mr burnfields welcome
I am
we will make a very good assistant no
he's evil we will protect you you have
the word of the most trusted institution
on Earth the Catholic Church
[Music]
your sole purpose in life is to serve me
now let's see
I just want a normal life again
God bless you Mr Renfield oh God bless
you nuns you're a hero Robert Montague
Renfield
let me explain I work for Dracula Count
Dracula
it's the real Dracula don't call me The
Dark One
other is the Lord of death
so you bring and people to eat well I do
other stuff like what washes cake no the
Cape is dry clean only strictly yeah I
will wear this it's flat yeah
I don't think he's such a bad guy but
you're never really going to be free
until you face him I will no longer
tolerate abuse I deserve happiness
okay you deserve only suffering I will
Unleashed everyone you care about will
suffer because you if you trade me we
have to stop him Before Sunset
[Music]
I deserve happiness and I take full
charge
[Music]
you know when something crazy happens
and someone's like it's okay I've seen
way worse everything I saw you do today
is gonna be my way worse my least
favorite part of the job
foreign
[Music]
here's what she says
to me
it's me
don't want to take my babies
[Music]
increase Terror through total chaos
I'm getting this out of here if you
could love somebody oh yeah yeah you
know how to fight kids
mom Mommy's with the maggots now
[Music]
meaning mining
you
got some big plans
you expect me to cut my hand to bring
some vigilante ghosts back from his
grave man you crazy play the damn game
[Music]
I saw them die
what do you know about devilro the
children's ghost story most ghost
stories
of some basis and Truth The Deadly night
happen right out there yeah yeah
Michaels
I'm gonna take your life
that which brought him back from the
dead to seek his Revenge come home come
home
bloodline of all involved pause
my bloodline
come home
foreign
Boogeyman of the sound
some have dubbed him the Lua Keeper of
the graveyard The Giver of Life and the
master of the Dead
wait
I should warn you before you step inside
the house this could change the course
of your entire life I'm not afraid of a
couple ghosts
[Music]
this Mansion is unhinged
the ghosts definitely don't want to
leave
death perks around every corner
God give us a break there's so many bad
people in the world haunt them amen
I do like surprises is anybody else
seeing this
we're gonna fight whether we like it or
not or else we're stuck here for
eternity
if this comes down to an exorcism we're
big trouble
but there's always room
for one more
[Music]
Tran was mugged he was tall he had hair
that was sticking out of a what a top
hat yup Top Hat yes yes Top Hat you
would pull a rabbit out of it probably
uh eyes they were a bit uh something
nice like a raccoon they set back
and he was smiling like yeah like that
exactly is this the man who mugged you
wow you just did that just now
but it looks like this is home for the
night
goddamn wind
Clarence
local officials have declared a
Statewide emergency as these
unprecedented storms continue to rain
sure got a Bus full of prisoners heading
our way got caught in the storm and need
a place to hunker down until it's safe
watch on your best behavior while we're
here
straight you're in my house
I will not hesitate to shoot you if I
have to y'all don't think this is cruel
and unusual right here
they got in your damn police station
storm brought him in could be infested
with them by now if you want to survive
the night we're gonna have to find a way
to get along keep an eye on him that's a
Bonafide cop killer right there
we're all gonna get eaten alive
[Music]
you got one shot Sheriff
here to taste like chicken
[Music]
all right baby
we have to help them
thanks for helping me you're safe now
along with
Brothers
[Music]
just the two of you running all this
land
that's right and who's this
yeah I'm sorry I talked to him
he said that mother is the name for God
on the lips and hearts of all children
she can be glorious
[Music]
fulfilled with Wrath
her family
there's no telling what she'd be capable
of
laughs
[Music]
everyone who ever lived here Falls
victim to some tragedy
like her daughter a year ago
my daughter was my whole life
to hear her voice again
I will give all I have
if someone wants to be heard
we are here
[Music]
that woman called the spirits and they
answered
you saw what I saw for once in your life
admit that you were up against something
bigger than you
tonight we are all afraid
we cannot hide from our ghosts
whether they are real or not
foreign
[Music]
Invisible Man plagues the town of iping
what Truss
clearly the vocal viping have lost the
ability to hear the words coming out to
their own mouths
yeah
it ain't your ears to be deceiving you
Marvel
this is a manhancer
have you experienced any suspicious
occurrences
strange noises
Broken Window
no no
nothing like that
I can do many things while invisible
Adeline
things that ordinary men cannot
ask her
[Music]
it's crazed and he's dangerous
it's time you chose this lady
[Music]
it's blood on your hands
we have barely begun
[Music]
you hold it down Abigail you know better
than Adventure be on the path at night
should never come here
[Applause]
we'll be safe in the valley
thank you
where you think you're going
[Music]
hey
they sent me out to find you where's my
family
that can lead the Lord right to us
Sadler and bring her back
looks like you and these Partners now
they've always wondered how these things
work
foreign
[Music]